COLT MCANLIS: In this episode
of Cloud Performance Atlas,
I take a look at the right
way to profile a CDN.
Will our latency hit the mark?
Stay tuned to find out.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
In a previous episode, we talked
about how the Google Cloud Load
Balancer can be
supercharged to leverage CDN
capabilities for faster
content distribution
to your users, which
of course kicked off
a discussion with
multiple developers
about the nuances
of CDN performance
and how Google's stacked up.
Now the minimum
functionality for a CDN
is caching a requested
asset closer to users
so that future requests have
the lowest possible latency.
To see what this looks
like performance-wise,
we simply set up
an asset on the CDN
and fetched it via a cURL
command about 500 times or so.
You know things are working
properly when your graph looks
something like this.
You see a bunch
of slower requests
at the front of your
timeline, and then latency
drops significantly
once the caching occurs.
If you run the same test
but from various instances
distributed globally, you'll get
something that looks like this.
We placed an asset
on a server in Texas,
and fetched it from various
points around the world.
You can see how Google's
Edge Network properly cached
the asset and moved it closer
to the user for later fetches.
Now-- oh, by the way, if
you're super interested,
you can modify your
cURL command to spit out
all the subsections
of those requests
and graph those individually.
Now things like DNS
resolve time, connection,
and pre-transfer speeds can
vary between CDN providers.
So it's sometimes nice to see
how these things break out
so that you can
compare them properly.
Now, sadly, these tests show a
rough estimate of performance.
But to really show off
the power of Google's CDN,
you need to write a bigger test.
For example, the Cloud
Team built a test
using Vegeta running on
Google Container Engine, which
allowed each pod to scale
up to about 50,000 RPS.
And an even bigger test has
been done by the Cedexis Radar
Community, which
collects over 14
billion real-user
measurements each day
from users all around the
world across providers, which
means that you can
compare them and see which
one works for your situation.
If you're interested in
more information on either
of those tests, check out
the article for this video,
linked in the description
below, where you can also
find more great ideas on
how to optimize your Cloud
Performance, because when
it comes to performance,
every millisecond counts.
[MUSIC PLAYING]